at midnight on New Year's Eve January
1st marijuana became officially legal in
Nevada the seventh state to legalize
recreational marijuana Colorado
Washington Alaska Oregon California
Massachusetts and DC Maine also voted
for it but it has not taken effect yet
here's something interesting that I
would think is thinking of so question
two was the ballot question in Nevada
over a legal cannabis and it was
approved on November 8th with 55 percent
approval meaning 45% of the population
was against it you have a state in
Nevada where you can drink 24 hours a
day for free while sitting in casinos
wasting away your life's earnings you
can hire prostitutes legally in licensed
brothels outside of Clark County Nevada
right outside of it is where brothel
licensed brothels can exist uh but
nearly half the state thinks legalizing
a plant is bad that I really don't
understand yeah it's all about fear of
the unknown I guess to them things like
gambling and excessive drinking or just
kind of commonplace now but you know
marijuana there's still a stigma
attached to it even in a place like
Nevada
maybe that 45% wouldn't want the casinos
or the out-of-control drinking or the
prostitution either right but that's not
on the ballot I don't know is this the
path forward right are we starting to
see the acceleration of marijuana
legalization or do we have about I don't
know 50 days until Attorney General Jeff
Sessions is sworn in and starts
attacking legal cannabis all over the
country remember that the President
Obama administration has decided even
though marijuana is still illegal at the
federal level we are going to stay out
of the business of states that have
legalized it's almost like a pro states
rights position which is what you would
hear from Republicans Attorney General
Jeff Sessions could come in and in in
concert with Donald Trump say hey you
know what we're directing the DEA to
actually ignore state legalization and
target states where marijuana has been
legalized I thought they were the party
of states rights though now I forget
maybe maybe they're not well that's the
concern I mean that's something that's
completely within the rights of the
executive branch to do you don't have to
go through
the courts are Congress too to enforce
the law that is already on the books
they could completely undermine the
states right incredibly dangerous but at
least over the last 72 hours legal
cannabis in Nevada